La Diva de la Banda, Jenni Rivera.
Good evening.
There is late word tonight that searchers
have found the wreckage...
...rescue workers searching
for a plane have found wreckage.
...jet went missing, carrying latin
music superstar, Jenni Rivera.
This was a woman poised for superstardom.
Jenni got on the plane.
She went into the sky
and she never came back.
The missing recorders are so critical
to understanding this accident.
So you mean to tell me they found
Jenni Rivera's driver's license,
but they couldn't find that black box.
Who needed to cover up what?
It's a dangerous life to be a singer,
because these cartel,
they are more treacherous
than a rattlesnake.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
[IN SPANISH]
I wanted to leave this recorded with you, since...
...if it is going to end, it will end here.